revenu 97 il vous reste quatre heures
pour remplir votre feuille de
déclaration dite simplifiée mais qui
reste souvent très compliqué pour les
français au premier ministre a reçu le
président du cnpf les nageuses pas dit
non report de la loi sur les 35 heures
par semaine que lui demandait
ernest antoine seillière on continue
d'élire les présidents de région le
socialiste alain le vern élu à la tête
de la région haute normandie en
rhône-alpes charles millon n'entend pas
démissionner mais ne parvient pas à
trouver de vice président le
gouvernement veut humaniser la réforme
des hôpitaux mais il faut tout même
rationaliser le fonctionnement des
établissements des villes moyennes qui
vont désormais fonctionner en réseau
c'est notre enquête de ce soir n'y a pas
d'âge pour apprendre vous à découvrir
une étudiante de 81 ans au milieu des
jeunes de l'université de poitiers
elle entend bien réussir son hit zone
d'histoire médiévale
madame monsieur bonsoir si vous ne
l'avez pas encore fait on n'est le lundi
30 mars il vous reste quatre heures pour
remplir votre déclaration de revenus 97
et chaque année cette déclaration dite
simplifiée continue de poser des
problèmes comme en témoigne cette visite
cet après midi au centre des impôts
d'ivry sur seine en banlieue parisienne
arnaud goûter et diego garcia un coup de
tampon libérateur la déclaration était
remisée enregistré juste à temps avant
l'heure fatidique dans le hall du centre
des impôts c'est l'effervescence
le nez dans leur dossier les
retardataires calcul est rempli sur
place 400 personnes viennent ici chaque
jour
aujourd'hui elle était particulièrement
angoissée surtout lorsqu'une pièce
manque au dossier des contribuables pour
qui remplir la déclaration constitue une
véritable épreuve
vous êtes marié et la date de la date de
séparation
voilà et après chacun voilà chacun fait
sa déclaration pension alimentaire pour
ma mère la nuit chez moi à la 90 ans
patronne et elle a pas beaucoup de
revenus saison qui s'inquiètent parce
qu'ils savent pas trop où mettre les
montants comment il faut qu'ils
déclarent quand ils se sont mariés quand
ils ont divorcé ou quand il ya eu des
décès dans la famille donc moi ça se
passe bien les déclarations de revenus
arrivent par dizaines envoyé par la
poste il ya plusieurs jours pour les
retardataires ce soir après minuit il
sera trop tard et la punition est sévère
10 % de majoration n'y a pas
d'indulgence administration examine
toujours en cas de retards motivés au
cas par cas les excuse absolutoire qui
aurait fabriqué par les contribuables
lui il faut avoir un motif sérieux pour
que l'on puisse en tenir compte
il ne reste que deux solutions pour y
échapper trouver un bureau de poste ont
rouvert ce soir ou bien tout simplement
jouer les facteurs jusqu'à son centre d
un pic déclarant nous payons mais au
fait combien sommes nous à payer que
représentent nos impôts directs pour le
budget d'état réponse pascal golomer
près de 30 millions de foyers sont
censés avoir posté leur déclaration de
revenus ce soir mais la moitié d'entre
eux seulement sont imposables
le chiffre est en baisse c'est l'effet
notamment des déductions et incitations
fiscales
apparu au fil des années l'impôt sur le
revenu a rapporté en 1996 derniers
chiffres disponibles
314 milliards de francs cela ne
représente en fait que 20% du total des
recettes fiscales
loin derrière la tva 45% mais davantage
que l'impôt sur les sociétés ou la taxe
intérieure sur les produits pétroliers
une situation typiquement française le
poids de l'impôt sur le revenu dans
l'ensemble des prélèvements obligatoires
est parmi les plus faibles des pays de
l'osce et des 14%
c'est moins que l'allemagne par exemple
est beaucoup moins que le danemark qui
détient le record d'europe
enfin si l'on souhaite établir le
portrait du contribuable moyen
ces impôts s'élèverait entre cinq et
sept mille francs pour un revenu annuel
situé entre 100 et 150 mille francs
la rencontre très attendue a eu lieu cet
après midi le premier ministre a reçu le
président du cnpf ernest antoine
seillière au menu un thème unique les 35
heures par semaine qui doivent être voté
demain par le parlement le président du
patronat voulait obtenir que l'ensemble
de la loi soit repoussé de deux ans à
l'échéance de l'an 2000 de refus des
premiers ministres laurent bailly jean
louis moulin
cela faisait six mois qu'un président du
cnpf n'avait foulé le pavé de matignon
motif de la rupture
les 35 heures bien su aujourd'hui le fil
du dialogue est renoué ernest antoine
seillière a été reçu par le premier
ministre
flanqué pour l'occasion de martine aubry
et dominique strauss kahn
si l'ambiance fut prof oise le patron
des patrons n'a rien obtenu sur le fond
ce serait une très bonne surprise si le
modifier la loi qui était sur le point
d'être adoptée je crois malheureusement
que nous ne pouvons pas y compter de
même qu on nous a refusé l'idée que
j'avais avancé que l'on puisse repousser
de deux ans l'échéance d'application de
la loi à 2002 pourtant de vive voix
aujourd'hui et par courrier ces derniers
dans le président du cnpf n'a cessé
d'alerter le premier ministre sur les
conséquences néfastes à ses yeux des 35
heures qui entraîneront dit il de
sérieuses difficultés économiques et
sociales très négatives pour l'emploi
quant à la dénonciation récente des
conventions collectives dans la banque
l'industrie du sucre et le commerce en
centre ville elle ne fait que traduire
explique-t-il le malaise des
entrepreneurs le gouvernement campe donc
sur ses positions le patronat aussi et
en attendant le projet de loi sur les 35
heures lui poursuit son cheminement
parlementaire demain les députés
procéderont à un vote solennel sur ce
texte et il repartira aussitôt au sénat
où sera probablement taillés en pièces
par les sénateurs puis reviendra une
troisième fois devant les députés et là
il sera adopté définitivement et même le
patron des patrons ne se fait pas
d'illusions la loi sera bel et bien
adopté tel quel les élections de
présidents de conseils régionaux se
poursuivre
kaka ce matin un rond après la démission
du président de droite élu grâce aux
voix du front national la semaine
dernière c'est un socialiste qui a été
élu alain le vern
il dispose d'une majorité relative dans
la mesure où pour ne pas bénéficier
et des voix du fn la droite n'a pas
voulu présenter de candidat pour autant
ce nouveau président risque d'avoir bien
du mal à gouverner sa région reportage
guilaine chenu et bruno l'hiver tout si
le maire 23 voix élu le nouveau
président de région c'est donc lui à la
longueur pour obtenir cette victoire il
aura fallu deux élections et à chaque
fois trois tours de scrutin
son premier geste écoute son
prédécesseur antoine roussennac à qui il
sert la main ses premiers mots sont
aussi pour ses adversaires de droite
je voudrais rendre hommage à monsieur
ruffenach mon prédécesseur à cette
fonction et saluer monsieur lozès dont
notre assemblée retiendra le geste
républicain hommage à jean paul gauzès
éphémère président rpr élu avec le
soutien du front national est on si je
démissionnais une droite qui aujourd'hui
ne présente pas de candidats votent
blanc hells affronter dans les urnes le
front national la gauche et lutte
ouvrière
l'élection est alors programmée alain le
vern l'emportent à la majorité relative
une élection qui se joue cette fois dans
le calme les incidents de la semaine
dernière ont laissé des traces
une élue de droite molesté se présente
casqués et antoine ruffenach dénonce des
violences orchestrées selon lui par la
gauche mais le fascisme de gauche existe
aussi un fascisme de gauche sectaire
menaçant i 2 une heure après son
élection le nouveau président alain le
vern bien dit
entre nous en minorité un avant-goût de
difficultés qui l'attendent à la tête
d'une région une et dispose que d'une
majorité relative
évidemment c'est majorité relative sont
des majorités par définition fragile et
nous une victoire modeste pour ce proche
de laurent fabius qui décrochent
aujourd'hui une sixième région pour la
gauche
on a un peu l'udf charles millon élu
grâce au soutien du front national
persiste et signe il n'entend pas
démissionner même s'ils n'arrivent pas à
former l'exécutif de sa région
on en est à la quatrième session est
toujours pas de vice président benoît
gadret didier guyot pour la quatrième
fois ils se sont réunis pour élire les
vice-présidents et pour la quatrième
fois en dépit des protestations des élus
de gauche
il n'y a pas eu de vote et pour cause
charles millon utilise toutes les
ficelles juridiques et politiques pour
retarder le scrutin
il veut désormais saisir les coûts
hautes autorités de l'état sur la
régularité de l'accord passé entre
l'indépendantiste savoyards et la gauche
et en attendant le président millions
assure qu'il peut gérer seul la région
je suis aujourd'hui l'exécutif que vous
le voyez vous voyez pas si oui alors une
illustration c'est que le président peut
assumer tout seul
les fonctions et que comme je suis
j'assume toutes mes responsabilités je
les assumerai par rapport à l'assemblée
par la commission permanente par rapport
à l'administration par rapport aux
autres partenaires de la région c'est
une escroquerie politique c'est une
escroquerie politique donc il n'ya pas
d'exécutif dans cette région vous ne
pouvez pas vous enfermez complètement
sans tenir compte de cette réalité
vous ne pouvez pas monsieur millions
sauf avoue s'enfermer dans une monarchie
absolue
vous ne pouvez pas diriger la région de
cette façon pour dénoncer ce qu'elle
appelle un puts la gauche a déposé un
recours devant le tribunal administratif
à droite l'attitude du président sème le
trouble
charles millon c'est qu'une quinzaine
d'élus lui fait défaut sans front
national il n'y a plus d'espoir de
majorité j'ai tout
c'est quelque chose de catastrophique la
séance est quelque chose d'un digne de
la démocratie
je crois qu'il faut que charles millon
se ressaisissent post un homme peut
toujours se ressaisir
le paradoxe est telle que le front
national qui avait aidé à l'élection de
charles millon s'en prend désormais lui
aussi aux méthodes du président en sa
qualité des nues et de professeurs de
droit bruno gollnisch a invité charles
millon a respecté la loi
ce soir la prochaine session a été
reportée à lundi prochain élection de
l'idf jean luc poudroux à la tête du
conseil général de l'île de la réunion
et élection surprise ce matin à la
présidence du conseil général de haute
corse qui basculent à gauche en raison
d'une défection d'un élu de droite c'est
le radical socialiste jean paul giacobbi
qui a été élu udf qui risque
d'éclatement après ces élections
régionales est réuni depuis le début de
l'après midi rendez vous très très
discret afin de ne pas médiatiser la
réunion dit-on dans l'entourage du
président de l'udf françois les hôtes le
brillant la république lui comme il l'a
promis la semaine dernière lors de son
intervention à la télévision a commencé
ses consultations afin de moderniser la
vie politique du pays
aujourd'hui il a déjà reçu cinq
personnalités les présidents du sénat de
l'assemblée nationale et des chefs de
partis comme françois hollande françois
léotard ou encore robert hue
véronique saint pulgent quand tout le
monde rêve d'une vie politique
moderniser jacques chirac veut la faire
et ils consultent après le président de
l'assemblée nationale le président du
sénat les 13 chefs de partis vont
pendant une semaine se succéder à
l'elysée exception faite de jean marie
le pen qui n'est pas invité la place des
femmes
le cumul des mandats la réforme du
scrutin régional les sujets sont
porteurs et chacun a ses idées
je suis convaincu que pour vaincre une
certaine forme de résistance du milieu
politique et pour vaincre la résistance
également ou en tout cas la résistance
légale légitime du conseil
constitutionnel il faut que l'on puisse
recourir au référendum selon l'article
en ouvrant ce dossier jacques chirac
veut surtout se mettre en phase avec le
plus grand nombre de citoyens se placer
au-dessus de la mêlée mais aussi ne pas
laisser tout le terrain au premier
le gouvernement s'apprête en effet à
présenter le texte sur le cumul des
mandats dans dix jours il faut aller
vite et les socialistes en tout cas eux
sont déjà partis dans la course
le 6 avril c'est jacques chirac qui
recevra lionel jospin pour faire le
point avant d'entamer une nouvelle série
de consultations avec des noms
politiques représentants d'associations
ou d'entreprises
c'est donc un paradoxe le président de
la république et le premier ministre
sont engagés dans une course où chacun
veut apparaître comme celui qui aura
initié et puis réaliser cette fameuse
modernisation puis encore dans un
communiqué ce soir le front national qui
est exclue il faut le savoir de ces
rendez-vous estime que cela aboutit en
fait à rejeter hors de la république
tous les français qui votent front
national
et puis encore un remaniement technique
au sein du gouvernement madame catherine
trautmann ministres agriculture ne fera
plus fonctions de porte parole du
gouvernement et martine aubry se voit
adjoindre un ministre délégué à la ville
claude bartolone et une secrétaire
d'état à la formation professionnelle
nicole péry justement la ministre de
l'emploi et de la solidarité martine
aubry accompagnée de bernard kouchner
ministre de la santé ont exposé
aujourd'hui leur politique hospitalière
ils veulent rompre avec une rigueur
budgétaire excessive une gestion
autoritaire c'est une critique indirecte
du plan d'alain juppé ils veulent
également lancer une concertation sur
les 35 heures l'hôpital pour autant la
révision de la carte sanitaire sur le
terrain se poursuivent il s'agit de
tisser des réseaux complémentaires entre
les hôpitaux des villes moyennes qui ne
pourront pas continuer à tout faire
c'est notre enquête de ce soir dans la
région de pithiviers gilles marine et
emmanuel pic l'hôpital de pithiviers
un établissement qui dessert 97 communes
70000 personnes
en fait toute la partie nord du loiret à
temps menacée de disparition cet hôpital
généraliste fonctionne désormais en
réseau avec seul ou détente dans
l'essonne à 35 km de là ensemble les
deux structures s'adresse à 150 mille
personnes le réseau c'est le partage des
tâches ainsi pithiviers à renoncer en
chirurgie aucune intervention
chirurgicale
atelier elles ont lieu sur le plateau
technique de l'hôpital d'étampés
mais les patients sont vues en
consultations de chirurgie et
d'anesthésié à pithiviers et ne vont
être au l'intervention chirurgicale
en revanche le réseau a permis le
maintien à pithiviers d'un service
d'urgences qui fonctionne 24 heures sur
24 avec des équipes des tâches et des
tendres bien tous les médecins des deux
services disposeront de moyens
permettant de se concerter
images à l'appui sur l'état des malades
une facture d'une entorse cheville
vous êtes examinée par un médecin qui ne
sait pas s'il faut savons mettre un
plâtre opérer et là parce qu'il est
transféré une image d'un chirurgien
orthopédique à étant qu'il ira qui
donnera par téléphone la conduite à
tenir
80% des patients admis aux urgences ne
présente pas de blessure très grave cela
continueront à être soignés sur place
la maternité c'est désormais un service
commun ou deux établissements et là
encore il y as partage des tâches des
accouchements simple c'est pithiviers
avec toutes les garanties de sécurité y
compris un bloc opératoire c'est
l'équipe bordeaux rennes bastia nat 1 2
tab leur animation de le faire
évidemment la plupart des vêtements ne
décide pas les bébés ne sais pas si ses
soins ça nous permet de questions
éventuelles et pour les grossesses à
risque notamment multiples pithiviers
devra obligatoirement dirigé ses
patientes sur et en mieux équipés seront
définis un partage des compétences la
réalisation à pithiviers des
accouchements normaux
survenant après la fin du 8e - excluant
les accouchements prématurés quand c'est
possible ses patientes seront dirigés
sur et tente des transports il y en aura
beaucoup dans ce système ajoutons à cela
la possibilité de pratiquer une
opération à pithiviers à l'exception
d'une césarienne
il faut donc sécuriser le réseau et
c'est là qu'intervient le samu basé à
orléans
il devrait bientôt implantée à
pithiviers une équipe mobile d'urgence
et de réanimation
en fait la pièce qui manque actuellement
au puzzle une révolution pour la
sécurité sociale le lancement courant
avril en bretagne à titre expérimental
d'une
cartes magnétiques des cartes vitale qui
remplacera la feuille rose la feuille
maladie les informations transmises
immédiatement grâce à 7k permettront un
remboursement beaucoup plus rapide des
patients
maurice papon après avoir assisté aux
obsèques de sa femme vendredi en région
parisienne étaient présents dans le box
des accusés cet après midi à bordeaux
son avocat maître jean marc varaut a
repris sa plaidoirie interrompu la
semaine dernière l'avocat a choisi dans
un premier temps de dénoncer l'idée de
crimes de bureau qui selon lui ne repose
sur aucun socle juridique
dominique verdeilhan patrick des schleck
a le visage marqué des lunettes aux
verres fumés maurice papon reprend sa
place dans le box sol un costume sombre
et une cravate noire rappelle le deuil
de l'accusé il est là pour assumer pour
dire non l'accusation plam péremptoire m
e varaut à l'intention des jurés
quelques minutes plus tard il n'est pas
homme à démissionner n'est pas homme à
déserter même dans le malheur un malheur
que m e varaut s'était juré de ne pas
utiliser comme argument de plaidoirie
alors avec tact l'avocat choisi ces
termes il n'ya pas de commune mesure ni
t-il entre ceux qui sont morts sans
sépulture est celui qui est là dans le
box puis audacieux m 20 euros poursuit
maurice papon n'a plus quelqu'un auprès
de lui pour dire en fin de semaine que
la justice l'a acquitté a quitté le
maître mot d'un combat qui va durer
trois jours et lors d'une séance de
dédicaces improvisée
m e varaut se lance dans la confidence
j'ai pas écrit
c'est vraiment oui
le plu lire ne plus dessiner pu faire
l'aquarelle
pu écrire alors il reste à mettre
varrault à convaincre dans ce dossier
dit il n'y a pas d'ordre de maurice
papon
il n'y a que des notes d'information à
l'intention de son supérieur quelques
heures plus tôt l'avocat s'était tourné
vers l'accusé je crois lui at il dit que
vous avez gardé la maison en attendant
le retour de la république les ministres
de l'agriculture européens se retrouvent
demain à bruxelles pour débattre de la
nouvelle réforme de la politique
agricole commune qui vise globalement
réduire les aides général pour les
remplacer en partie seulement par des
aides directes
pour bruxelles il s'agit de se mettre en
ordre de marche face à la concurrence
mondiale notamment amérique le monde
agricole français et contre le
gouvernement aussi pour l'instant on
partage dans le gers une exploitation
particulièrement visés dans la mesure où
entre cultures élevage la production
n'est pas véritablement spécialisé jean
yves perrin nathalie gal tous les matins
la journée commence ainsi faire télé
vous nourrir la trentaine de vaches
nettoyer les tas éleveurs comme son père
comme son grand père à temps partiel car
michel baylac est aussi cultiva serez
vite y culteurs un agriculteur
polyvalent mais l'élevage reste le
secteur le plus menacé de sa ferme par
la future réforme de la politique
agricole commune
elle prévoit une baisse des prix de la
viande de 30%
je ne suis pas d'un naturel pessimiste
mais là il faut regarder les chiffrer et
c'est vrai qu'en matière d'élevage
l'élevage que vous êtes en train de
regarder
c'est un élevage traditionnel et ses
élevages traditionnels et bien yvonne
yvon fera disparaître
autre source d'inquiétude la baisse des
prix des céréales et des oléagineux 20%
en une fois qu'on pensait à seulement
50% par l'augmentation des étudiants
le coup est dur particulièrement pour
les oléagineux michel produit du soja
sur 20 hectares et craint de perdre 1500
francs par hectare
et s'il additionne baisse des prix et
compensations partielles la réforme mais
coûtera très cher j'ai fait mon calcul
avec bon ma production animale j'arrive
quasi mal à ça me le fera à sa 1000e
fran de perte de revenus sur
l'exploitation
je n'ai qu'une chose à faire supprimez
supprimez le var or je n'ai pas envie de
le faire quand je considère que si mon
petit peu d'élevage disparaît eh bien ça
veut dire qu on va s'orienter vers des
productions plus intensive et moins
respectueuses aussi il faut le dire de
l'environnement l'autre crainte des
agriculteurs gersois la course à
l'agrandissement l'agriculture survivra
toujours ce sont les agriculteurs qui
disparaîtront si là où il y avait trois
agriculteurs il y en a plusieurs mais il
aura comme bâle c'est le manque à gagner
par l'agrandissement de la surface mais
pour le ps est une catastrophe
un discours déjà entendu en 92 avant
l'application de la première réforme de
la pac
depuis les agriculteurs ont su s'adapter
aux conditions imposées par bruxelles
pragmatique la commission européenne qui
compte à nouveau sur cette faculté pour
prouver sur le terrain
le bien fondé de ces baisses de prix la
grande bretagne vient de perdre sa
dernière firme automobile indépendante
la plus prestigieuse sans aucun doute
rolls royce reprise par l'allemand bmw
qui fabriquait déjà un certain nombre de
moteurs réalisme économique cette vente
c'est tout de même un coup au coeur pour
les anglais londres et jelen
il va falloir s'y faire cette voiture
ils transportent la reine en toute
occasion qui emporta le dernier
gouverneur britannique loin de hong kong
qui chaque année à ascot permettent aux
belles de se faire remarquer ce fleuron
du chic british et donc pointe
un siècle d'histoire depuis qu'un
électricien et un fils de milliardaire
dessinèrent en 1906 leurs premiers
modèles
il y en aura 39 au total des voitures
officielles à la rolls branché de john
lennon quoi qu'on en dise est un peu de
la grande bretagne qui s'en va sur les
rives du rhin on a reçu l'assurance que
la voiture serait toujours construite en
grande bretagne qu'elle garderait son
côté british tout ce qui fait la malle
rolls une voiture si différente pour
trois milliards et demi de francs bmw a
donc racheté l'usiné de crewe mais ces
2500 salariés
la rolls on le sait est presque
entièrement fait main trente jours sont
nécessaires pour mettre au point une
seule voiture symbole de perfection et
de luxe rolls royce était la dernière
automobile anglaise appartenir à une
compagnie britannique est un groupe de
riches propriétaires ne se résout
toujours pas ce soir à rouler allemand
désormais et c'est plus qu'un noir c'est
une partie de notre histoire de notre
héritage et ça vaut la peine qu'on se
défende de murat à se battre et mw a
gagné une bataille mais pas la guerre
cette contre offensive semble bien vaine
la dernière rôle c'est déjà équipé d'un
moteur bmw et le constructeur allemand
envisage déjà de tripes et les vend dès
l'année prochaine
au risque pour rolls royce qui perdra
pas son âme car à jouer sur une
augmentation des ventes et un
élargissement de la gamme la compagnie
risque de perdre en prestige et en luxe
un million et demi de francs
l'exemplaire toutefois nous ne sommes
pas encore
symbole de son indépendance par rapport
au poids public la compagnie air france
vient de prendre livraison de son
premier gros porteurs long courriers un
boeing 777 préféré à l'européen airbus
dix autres appareils suivants il s'agit
pour la compagnie française se refaire
une place de choix sur les trajets qui
traverse l'atlantique dans l'état de
floride après qu'a relaté coeur c'est
une femme de 54 ans judy wanna know qui
a été exécutée accusé de plusieurs
meurtres cette exécution n'a pas
provoqué la même motion que la
précédente
actuellement 40 femmes attendent leur
exécution aux états unis et plus de 3000
à washington philippe gassot judy bueno
anneaux est la deuxième femme à avoir
été exécutée depuis que la cour suprême
a déclaré en 1976 la peine capitale
conforme à la constitution américaine et
cela après quatre années de moratoires
dus des bois noa noa été surnomme
la veuve noire du nom d'une araignée
tueur la justice l'a condamné à mort
pour avoir empoisonné son mari à
l'arsenic en 1971 puis avoir noyé son
fils handicapé en 1980 et ce n'est pas
tout l'homme avec lequel elle vivait
après la mort de son époux est décédé
dans des conditions mystérieuses des
traces d'arsenic ont été retrouvés quant
à son fiancé il est passé à côté de la
mort en 83 sa voiture avait été piégé
par une bombe
les anti peine de mort bien peu nombreux
ont manifesté la grande majorité des
américains considèrent elles que justice
est faite
la cousine de la condamner tente de
défendre sa mémoire elle n'avait pas
peur judy était redevenu chrétienne elle
n'était peut être pas aussi photogénique
que la jeune et belle carla thacker mais
c'était une bonne contiennent les anti
peine de mort avait misé sur carla
tucker pour que les femmes ne soient pas
exécutés
elle condamne et le combat était perdu
dudit est morte sur la chaise électrique
après que cinq mille volts lui a
traversé le corps ce témoin indique que
de sa cheville droite est sortie de la
fumée
c'est la première fois que l'on exécute
une femme en floride sur la chaise
électrique dans les territoires
palestiniens la journée de la terre qui
commémore la confiscation de terres au
profit de colons juifs en 1976 à d'un
lieu cette année encore à les
affrontements entre policiers israéliens
et manifestants qui ont fait au total
treize blessés parmi les palestiniens à
cette occasion on a vu brûler des
drapeaux israéliens mais aussi des
drapeaux américains quelques heures
auparavant l'envoyé spécial de
washington dennis france et est reparti
sans avoir pu vraiment relancer le
processus de paix dans la région
la situation de tension permanente qui
prévaut depuis l'arrivée de binyamin
netanyahu au poste de premier ministre
en israël en 1996 rendent de plus en
plus problématique la survie économique
des territoires palestiniens à l'exemple
de cet adolescent qui tous les jours
passent tant destine mans les postes de
police pour se rendre en israël
gagner sa vie jerusalem charland d
achraf à 15 6 jours par semaine il vient
vendre des objets aux conducteurs
israéliens à ce carrefour dans le
secteur juif de jérusalem les affaires
ne vont pas très bien et il devra passer
ici de longues heures jusqu'à ce qu'il
réalise son objectif gagner au moins 150
shekels l'équivalent de 250
il ne faut surtout pas que la police eut
des inspecteurs de la municipalité
fassent leur apparition
ashraf a déjà été arrêté à plusieurs
reprises
sa journée il l'a commencé tôt le matin
hyatt à son village fait de hébron à une
heure et demie de route de jérusalem
son père et ses deux grands frères au
chômage sont déjà partis à la recherche
d'un travail
ici c'est notre chambre à coucher avec
mes quatre frères ont dors par terre
voici les matelas que l'on range le
matin lorsqu'il fait très froid nos
soeurs elles sont six viennent dormir
avec nous ashraf a quitté l'école à
l'âge de 11 ans
la famille vit dans une extrême pauvreté
ici pas d'eau courante
ces enfants mangent de la viande une
fois par mois un plat de riz pour petit
déjeuner et c'est le départ
auto stop taxis collectifs achraf arrive
près du barrage israélien qui doit
contourner n'a pas de permis de séjour
en israël et risque la prison
les soldats l'ont remarqué mais le
laisse faire du moins pour cette fois
la route est libre h rap arrive à
jérusalem où il va cachés dans les
buissons une partie de sa marchandise
qui est arrêté les copains viendront
récupérer ce qui n'a pas été saisi il ya
de bons juifs et de bons arabes les
méchants aussi des deux côtés une partie
des conducteurs israéliens est sympa
d'autres pas du tout il y à deux mois
des flics m'ont passé à tabac j'ai même
été hospitalisé j'ai porté plainte
contre eux que veux tu faire quand on
sera plus grand je veux gagner de
l'argent avoir une maison peut-être même
un bout de terre à moins manger à sa
faim vivre bien c'est le seul rêve de
cet adolescent il ya des centaines
d'achat au carrefour en israël et en
cisjordanie
toute l'italie est passionné par la
naissance dans un hôpital de ravenne
d'un bébé dont la maman est tombé dans
le coma quelques semaines après la
conception de l'enfant malgré tout le
foetus et développer normalement la
jeune femme de 21 ans ne s'est pas
réveillé au moment de l'accouchement
mais elle a donné tout de même quelques
signes de vie très encourageant pour ces
médecins rome and child ce bébé une
petite fille du nom de shannon est un
miracle elle est née ce week-end par
césarienne au bout de sept mois de
gestation elle pèse 2 kg 4 et paraît en
bonne santé
rien pour le moment d'extraordinaire
seulement sa mère que voilà et depuis
six mois dans un coma considéré comme
irréversible
après une hémorragie cérébrale
l'opération a eu lieu ici à l'hôpital de
ravenne ce n'est pas à proprement parler
une première médicale des enfants sont
déjà nés ainsi
mais voilà que sharon la miraculée
pourrait à son tour suscité un miracle
la maman les dix ans n'est pas
complètement regette hâtive depuis six
mois donne des premiers signes de vie le
docteur lui attendre les battements du
coeur de la petite poêle et a demandé à
lady si elle entendait avec les venues
une petite larme de ses yeux ensuite
j'ai choisi le nom de ma petite fille
shannon et j'ai demandé à ma fille elle
a répondu oui avec les yeux en clignant
des paupières les médecins ont donc
aussitôt changé le traitement de lady et
pense avoir maintenant une petite chance
de la sauver sa famille sa mère ses
frères et soeurs qui vivent simplement
dans ces deux caravanes plus de ravenne
reprend espoir
en somme shannon en venant à la vie
aurait aussi redonner la vie à sa mère à
paris au salon professionnel des
dentistes les spécialistes ont mis en
lumière la possibilité de transmission
des caries dentaires de mère à enfant
attention il ne s'agit pas d'un
phénomène d'ordre génétique mais avant
tout d'un problème d'hygiène par exemple
lorsque la maman goûte la bouillie du
petit avant de la lui donner
françoise vallée raymond chaplin
reportage non le sucre et les bonbons ne
sont pas seuls responsables de la carie
les dentistes le savent bien la carré
est une maladie un fait
sur à l'origine des bactéries et plus
particulièrement une bactérie joue un
rôle capital dans la santé dentaire de
l'enfant une étude américaine récente
montre que cette bactérie est transmise
aux bébés par sa maman
les études qui viennent de sortir des
états unis et qui ont maintenant plus de
dix ans d'expérimentation montrent que
lorsqu'on analyse génétiquement la
structure de cette bactérie qui est le
streptocoques mutants ce qu'on trouve
chez l'enfant la structure génétique de
la bactérie chez l'enfant est exactement
la même génétiquement que celle de la
maman et pas de celle du papa ni de
celle de la nounou c'est typiquement la
même structure que celle de la maman
la bactérie se transmet oralement en
goûtant les plats par les bisous bref
des gestes quotidiens
l'étude montre que les dents de l'enfant
sont plus sensibles à cette bactérie
entre 18 mois et 3 ans d'où l'importance
d'avoir une bonne hygiène dentaire chez
la mère comme chez l'enfant
il faut consulter le plus tôt possible
dans la première année
la première année ça permettre aux
praticiens de donner des bons conseils
aux parents entre autres des conseils
sur l'alimentation et sur l'hygiène
puisque décline dans il faudrait qu'il y
ait nettoyage de 7 dans l'alimentation
reste un facteur de risque c'est elle
qui entretient les bactéries la hantise
et dentistes c'est le grignotage entre
les repas et le biberon sucre et le soir
avant de dormir
le dicton populaire a bien raison on a
l'âge de ses artères et lorsque celle ci
fonctionne bien et bien tout vous est
permis ou presque un exemple cette
étudiante de poitiers âgé de 81 ans qui
a décidé au milieu des petits jeunes de
reprendre ses études
un diplôme d'histoire médiévale jean
bernard schmid jean-paul chaussée alors
pour faire médiévale par ailleurs latine
on va savoir
cartable en main frédéric dévalent les
rues de poitiers et la cour à 14h à la
fin cherchez l'intrus
la moyenne d'âge dans cet amphithéâtre
et de 20 ans frédéric l on a 80 cette
année elle tente d'obtenir sa licence
d'histoire médiévale
je savais pas mal de choses et j'avais
l'impression que j'avais tout dans le
désordre et je voulais donc apprendre à
mettre de l'ordre et à travailler avec
méthode sur les sujets qui m'intéressait
la première année j'étais un peu
inquiète parce que je me demandais si ce
qui allait se passer
et puis comme j'ai vu que j'avais mes
examens j'ai continué mais que
greenpeace
lorsqu'il ya trois ans cette ancienne
documentaliste a décidé de commencer des
études d'histoire
elle n'a pas choisi les université du
temps libre réservée aux 3e à elle a
voulu connaître les joies des travaux
dirigés des devoirs à rendre des examens
à passer
bref un vrai cursus universitaire qui
aurait de quoi surprend choqué et très
assidus enfin fait même si elle n'est
pas un matériel presque j'ai baigné et
pour qu'elles aient toutes les étapes et
il en compte il ya une personne comme
elle se pose pas problème sans pause ça
n'a posé parfois quand vous tombez sur
je parle général en retraite il la
ramène un peu
frédéric habite une grande maison à une
soixantaine de kilomètres de poitiers
mais comme beaucoup d'étudiants elle a
été obligée de louer un studio en ville
la première année je ne savais pas si
j'avais si ça marche
alors je venais tous les jours je
prenais le car je me levais à 5 heures
du matin le car à 6 2 je repartais soir
j'étais assez fatigant de version latine
en exposer à préparer frédéric travail à
son bureau souvent jusqu'à minuit et son
goût pour l'histoire reste intacte
pourquoi ça vous plaît cette matière est
ce que ça me fait rêver
malgré la difficulté de certains cours
cette grand-mère érudite garde sa
motivation l'année prochaine pour ses 81
ans elle espère pouvoir préparer une
maîtrise sur richard coeur de lion
dangereux phénomène climatique el niño
exerce surtout son influence sur les
pays tropicaux pour autant les
spécialistes s'interrogent sur ses
effets dans l'hémisphère nord il faut
dire que les températures sont
exceptionnellement douces en cette
saison en france aujourd'hui 30 mars il
a fait sur ces images 24 degrés à
strasbourg la ville la plus chaude du
pays aujourd'hui mais aussi 16 degrés à
paris et à lille 14 à bordeaux 18 à
marseille dans le sud-est dans la région
de nice très exactement les fraises
primeur de carros sont en avance elles
ont bénéficié de 120 jours le soleil
depuis le début de l'hiver
reportage olivier théron signé bon le
village de carros accroché à la montagne
ou niçoise est le village d'une
princesse sous un baldaquin translucide
elle est jalousement protégé de tout ce
qui pourrait la gêner la fraises de
carros c'est la renommée du village ses
lettres de noblesse il faut neuf mois
pour qu'elle devienne rouge et craquante
neuf mois pendant lesquels henri giacomo
va surveiller ses rangées et attendre
cette année la princesse est précoce à
cause du soleil
et l'année de la décennie on a eu
rarement l'ensoleillement s'y vend donc
je vois que je pense que noir une
qualité exceptionnelle
la fraises de carros qui est maintenant
une appellation contrôlée à une amie de
taille la fraise espagnole
malgré ces atouts notre fraises se
heurte à la rentabilité 30 il ya dix ans
une quinzaine aujourd'hui les
producteurs ont opté pour la qualité
nous avons choisi nous la page a rossé
d'une variété hâtive unique makarov qui
produit très peu mais en qualité en goût
comme un bon verre avec une belle robe
alors qu'il est déduit donc que si vous
favoriser les productions espagnoles
vous prenez des variétés comme camaro ça
tu dollar ainsi de suite dyala au moins
dix ou vingt neuf arrêtés très grosse
productrice qu'il faut jusqu'à un kilo
de fraises partie malgré tout et grâce
aux 120 jours de soleil de cet hiver la
princesse de carros est particulièrement
réussi et goûteuse beatles et brocarde
raccorde à ne pas les atouts pour faire
un bon cru 98 la fraises de carros est
distribué dans tout le sud est de la
france mais elle est dit-on tellement
bonne que la majorité de sa production
est consommée dans les environs voilà le
rappel des titres de ce lundi d'abord on
continue d'élire les présidents de
région le socialiste alain le vern a été
élu à la tête de la région normandie en
rhône alpes
charlie on n'entend pas démissionner
mais ne parvient pas à trouver deux vice
présidents puis le premier ministre a
reçu le président du cnpf me réjouis pas
dit non au report de la loi sur les 35
heures par semaine que lui demander
ernest antoine seillière dans un instant
la météo sophie davant 21h à la 12ème
cérémonie des 7 d'or présenté par claude
sérillon présidée par gérard plein une
soirée que vous devrez en direct et que
nous dédions à l'une des réalités
réalisatrice de ce journal michel gare
décédé des suites d'un cancer à l'âge de
60 ans voilà je vous souhaite une
excellente soirée sur notre chaîne
bonsoir à dos